you've done a lot of work on prison
reform in your life and you think that
certain kinds of reform in our system
would actually change the electoral
process drastically absolutely
we lost Florida Democrats lost Florida
if African American men had not been
disqualified from voting by
disproportionate arrests for drugs
disproportionate conviction for drugs
we don't once Florida in a landslide you
have some southern states where 30% of
African American especially men can't
vote because they have drug felonies now
I'm going to tell you something I spent
my 20s in a drug infested din of crime
and iniquity Yale University right I saw
more drugs being done in more ways off
of more surfaces by more kinds of people
than I ever saw in any black community
but the cops never kicked in the doors
the police never showed up none of those
kids went to prison so all those kids
can vote and the point you've made is
that many times if someone has a chance
of being convicted or having to face a
jury they can plead they can take a much
lesser charge and say I did it even if
they maybe didn't do it but they don't
want to be up for 25 years and what they
don't maybe realize at the time is they
will lose their right to vote in many
many states they will but let me ask you
a question
you watch CSI and all this stuff no I
don't know I really but okay sure yeah
yeah what percentage of people do you
think in jail right now went to trial I
have no idea I'm sorry I would I would
want I would say I would maybe what
forty percent but forty percent yeah
three three percent yeah ninety-seven
percent of people are too poor to afford
a lawyer and a prosecutor comes in says
we're gonna give you a hundred years or
we'll give you two but you gotta plead
and everybody pleads right and so and so
here's the thing if you care about the
environment you have to care about
incarceration because african-americans
are disproportionately incarcerated
disproportionately stripped of our right
to vote and then therefore can't show up
at the polls to vote for Democrats if
you care about women's choice whatever
you care about at the end of the day if
you don't stick up for democracy for
everybody you don't get democracy for
anybody and that's what happened in
selection
[Applause]
you